This is a longer dua, but it's beautiful.
The Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam when he would go to the morning prayer.
See, real quick, how do you get light on the Day of Judgment?
The worships that you do in the darkness of dunya give you light on Day of
Judgment. The Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam said, "When you walk to Fajr prayer, it's dark out.
That's light on the Day of Judgment.
When you walk to Isha prayer, it's dark out.
Anything done in that darkness for God is light on the Day of Judgment."
So, on his way walking to the morning prayer, he used to say this dua.
Allahumma ja'alli nuran fi qalbi.
Write some of this down.
If you don't get the whole thing, write some of it.
"Oh Allah, place my light in my heart.
Waj'alli nuran fi sam'i.
Oh Allah, place light in how I listen.
Waj'alli nuran fi basari.
Oh Allah, place light in how I look at things.
Waj'alli nuran an yamini.
Oh Allah, put light on my right side.
Wa an yasari, on my right side.
Waj'alli nuran min bayni yadayya wa min khalfi.
Put nur in front of me.
Put nur behind me.
Put nur all around me, ya Allah."
And then the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam, he would say, "Oh Allah, just make me nur.
Make me nur."
And that brings me to my next point, which is we all have to become the
light for other people in our lives.
We cannot be the sources of other people's darkness.
We have to become the light for other people.
That means we help them to goodness.
We help them to do khair.
We help them to know God.
We help them to whatever will bring light and clarity to their lives.
And you have to surround yourself with other people that have light.
Because on my day that I'm feeling down, as long as I got a ace that
got light, we're good for the day.